abone ol
[Müzik]
O
dilini sustura bilen var mı mı Evet yani
renk alırsın
Ya hayır yönelik alırsın
bu süper Ben de zihnimi susturamıyorum
gruba giriyorum Yani hayır diyenler
dedim Çünkü benim için zil Aslında
susturulamayan ve bir o kadar da İronik
olan bir şeydir Çünkü Zihni biliyorsunuz
zihin size her zaman iyi şeyleri
söylemez ve her zaman kötü şeyleri de
söylemez sizin yönlendiren yerleşiriz
indir ve susturduğunu zaman Aslında bir
bakıma kendi yaşam fişini çekmiş
olursunuz Buz ve zihin en önemli şeyi
size verenler ilham Çünkü ilham olmayan
insan yaşamayan insandır ve ilhamın da
aslında üç tane usulü vardır Birincisi
Aha mont Yani bir iş yapıyorsunuz Çok
sıralanmış ve bir şey geliyor bir anda
eliniz ayağınız böyle buz kesiyor bir
şekilde Nefesin alışverişini hızlanıyor
ve diyorsunuz ki işte ilham geldi
ikincisi Medyum Medyum fal bakan veya
Sizin geleceğinizi tamir eden kişilerden
bahsetmiyorum Ama kişinin kendi
duygularını en iyi şekilde ifade ettiği
biçimdir Medyum o aks Çok güzel film
çeker belkisi çok güzel resim yapar
cekisi De ki ben diyeceğim ki C grubuna
giriyorum çok güzel yazar
bu kişinin kendini ifade etme biçimidir
Sonuncusu da üründür tabii ki de ilham
geldi Bunu nasıl ifade edeceğimizi
seçtiniz bir ürün ortaya çıkması
gerekiyor
buna da ürün adını veriyoruz Bence
grubuna giriyorum ben yazmayı çok
severim Çünkü bazı duygularımın
birileriyle konuşarak resmederek veya
şarkı yaparak geçebileceğini düşünüyorum
o yüzden yazmaya özen gösteriyorum şimdi
gelin benim ilham serüveninde bakalım
yanındaki beyefendi Vay bozan Dedem bu
fotoğraf 2019 yılında çekilmişti Dedem
2017'nin sonunda kanser teşhisi konmuştu
ve 2019'da İlkiz attığı gün akşam
yemeğine çıkmıştık
neden Dedemi koydum çünkü dedem benim
hayatımda gerçekten çok fazla etkisi
olan biriydi bu da kabul etmesende Çünkü
diğer dedim pek tanıma fırsatı
bulamamıştım her Yapacağım işte ona da
şaşırdım ve her cuma akşamı işten
çıkarken beni arardı veya ben ona
arardım O basitçe benim yaşamdaki tekrar
Aferim
Dedem 2019'da kanseri atlattıktan sonra
2020'de tekrar kanser oldu ve 2020'nin
Mayıs ayında maalesef kaybettik
kaybettikten sonra Aslında için biraz
sıcaklığıyla galiba demiştim ki ya 70
yaşıma kadar ne yapacağımı biliyorum
çünkü yetmiş yaşına kadar yaşamıştı ama
70'ten sonrası biraz muallak Çünkü
70'den sonrası onunla yaptığı bir şey
yoktu ve ama tanışma fırsatım yoktu o
yüzden böyle bir şey söylemiştim
w2020 1 mayıs'ında şöyle bir şey çıktı
karşıma İki Yol İkisi de karanlık ne
yapacağımı kesinlikle bilmiyorum Çünkü
gerçekten büyük bir boşluğun içine
düşmüştüm henüz Bunu ben de farkında
değilim şu anda daha yeni yeni farkına
varıyorum ve dedim ki kendi kendime bu
hayatın olağan akışına bazı şeyleri
değiştirmen gerekiyor Çünkü böyle
gidemez bazı şeyleri sıra sıralarından
kurtulmak gerekiyor ve ben ilhamını
seçtim ve yazmaya başladım O iki yolda
yürümeye Karar verdim çünkü Bence ilham
olmayan insan değil tek yolda yürümek
iki yoldan birini bile seçemez ölmüştür
çünkü
ve bu ilham arayışım mm 21'in Temmuz
ayına kadar sürdü ve dedim ki ne
yapmalıyım bundan nasıl kurtuluruz
düştüm boşluklar nasıl çıkarım nasıl
daha iyi hissederim benim yaptığım şey
yapayım dedim ve seyahat etmeye karar
verdim çünkü Avrupa gençlik parlamentosu
girdikten sonra çok fazla seyahat ettim
seyahat ettiğim de çok güzel kültürler
tanıdım çok güzel insanlarla tanıştım o
dönemde korno yüzden bu Herkesi
istediğin zaman seyahat edemiyorsunuz
baktım nereye gidebilirim en cazip
opsiyon bosna-hersek'te bosna-hersek'te
nereye gidebilirim Mostar Mostar deyince
bir şey oldu bir düşündüm de demin
işyeri takvimleri aklıma geldi Dedem
sanırım 97 yılında Moskova'ya gidiyor
sonra her sene iş yerine bastırdı
takvimine modların resmini koyuyor yani
olsa köprüsünün Oradan tanıyorum Yüksek
ihtimalle 14 yaşına kadar falan Mostar
benim için köprüden ibaret ve demin
takviminde Benim Türkiye'de zannettiğim
bir yerdi mostar'a gitmeye karar verdim
motora gitmek için hemen o ve indim
Saraybosna yedikten sonra koştur koştur
trenlerine gittim Booster abi tren
bileti aldım otele döndüm Ertesi gün ne
yapacağımı düşünüyorum
ama hiçbir fikrim yok yani çünkü Danışır
kendi Annemle babam o sıra gideceğimi
söyledim yani onlarda tenezzül etmedi
sormaya hiçbir şekilde Ne yapacağımı
konuşamadık Tek bildiğim şey ertesi gün
o sıra gidiyorum Muhtar ne kadar büyük
muhtarda ne yapabilirim Ben niye motora
gidiyorum Bunun cevabı kesinlikle bende
yok Beklerken Aslında bu sorunun
cevabını buldum ve bu da zilini ölüm
zihindeki ölümle alakalı bir kavram da
Çünkü bana göre zihin ölüm imkansız bunu
da güzel örneğini vereyim Örneğin kişi a
Vahip 1997 yılında Bosna Hersek'in
Mostar a gitti ve orada Ariel diye
biriyle tanıştırdı Ariel ile beraber iki
gün boyunca çok güzel çay kahve içtiler
eğlendiler Yemek yediler ve Vahip 97
yılında tekrar Mersin'e geri döndü Sonra
bayi 2020 yılında vefat etti Şimdi Vahip
türkiyedekiler için öldü mü
UV Vay ip Ailesi için Öldü mü Öldü Peki
bu ayıp Sizce muzlardaki Ariel için
öldüğümü ölmemiş Çünkü halen Ariel onun
zihninde yaşadığını düşünüyor ve
zihninin bir köşesinde vacip yaşıyor ve
on Kendime şunu söyledim Sen mu sıra
gidiyorsun Çünkü deden mostar'da ölmedi
o orada Moskova gittiğim zaman ertesi
gün trene bindim trene binmeden önce
biliyorsunuz Doğu Avrupa'da her şey bu
kadar hızlı ilerlemez her şey zamanında
kalkmaz bu anda bir büyük şapkalı adam
gördüm ve büyük şapkalar ama dikkatimi
dikkatini verdiğim zaman onun bir
irtibat memur olduğunu fark ettim trenin
kalkışını şey yapan ve dedim ki Aha işte
ilham geldi yazmalıyım hemen koştur
koştur Valizleri bile peronda bırakarak
en yakın marketimiz yere girdim ve dedim
ki defter istiyorum zaten anlaşamıyoruz
dediler ki pandemi var yani defter
satmıyor zaman küçük bir şeyler olur mu
Hemen olur dedim Aldım fren zaten
geldiğimde kalkıyordu trene bindim ve
büyük şapkalı adamı kaleme aldım
en büyük şapkalı bir adam var peronda
üniformalı galiba tren geliyor tren
gidiyor o reflektörlü sallıyor
hareketleri yavaşlıyor sanki rayların
ucunda yaşlı galiba falan geliyor tren
gidiyor o kondukları selam veriyor
postaları yakından eski duruyor memur
galiba tren geliyor fren gidiyor o kendi
cennetinde yaşamaya devam ediyor büyük
şapkalarını Hayal edemediğiniz ben de o
zaman fotoğrafını çekmiştim aynen şöyle
bir memurdu peki burada büyük şapkalı
adam Aslında kim bunu iyice araştırmak
halletmek lazım Çünkü büyük şapkalardan
Aslında hayatımızın parçası ama biz
onların farkında değiliz burada da benim
onu fark edip sürecimde demin ölümüyle
başlayan ve benim bir Uyanış olarak
nitelendirdiği mser benim bir parçasıydı
Çünkü ben o gün Garda da nedensizce
amaçsızca sadece motora gideceğim
biliyordum ama benimle beraber seyahat
eden herkes Belki de farklı telaşlarım
içindeydi ekonomiden Bu bir şeyden
endişeliler di veya Acelesi vardı ve
büyük Şakaladım onlar fark etmemişti ama
ben büyük şapkalı mı Adamı fark etmiş ve
kilometrelerce öteden bir Türk olarak
ona şiir yazmıştım
Evet şimdi de gelin ilhamı kabul
ettiğiniz zaman neler yapabileceğinizi
ve gerçekten benim sevgime gelelim
kapıda zaten görmüşsünüzdür çok fazla
İmam var az önce biyografileri 64 dakika
sürdü Aslında ben 19 yaşındayım 2002
doğumluyum çok sevilerek ve sevgiyle
büyütülen bir çocuktum Ben oyunların
bana ör geldiğini düşünüyorum sizden
bugün için ricam beni Sadece Z kuşağının
bir temsilcisi olarak görmeniz 2002
yılından sonra doğanyiğitler buydu asla
ben pek şaşırmadım Bu hale gelmiyor
Çünkü yani o yaşta böyle böyle
geziyordum ve çok tatlı oluyordu yani şu
an hıza ben tatlı verdim O zaman Tabi ki
de işin ciddiyetinin farkında değildim
ama işte bu arkadaş bu arkadaşa dönüştü
ve şu an sizinle beraber
bir süre önce teması altında bir şeyler
konuşuyor ben 2019 yılında Avrupa
gençlik parlamentosu dahil oldum zor bir
süreçti Çünkü çok fazla rekabet var
Türkiye'de her şeyde olduğu gibi Ve bu
rekabetin içinden çıkmak neredeyse
imkansız en son kişi Evet okuldan ki ben
de kendimi Elif'i okuldan geldi mi
olarak sayıyorum bu süreçler çok güzel
ülkeler gezme fırsatım oldu ülkeleri
gezerken yeni insanlarla tanıştım en
önemlisi de kendi kültüründen bir şey
bırakırken her zaman karşı tarafın
kültürel önemli bir şeyler almaya Özen
gösterdim ayak izi mi başka
arkadaşlarımın Farklı ülkelerde yaşayan
arkadaşlarımın ayak izine denk düşürdüm
burada görebilirsiniz ama burada fark
ettim iki ana çıkarım da vardı birincisi
aşırı eşitlikten Doğan eşitsizlikle
Çünkü gerçekten bazen toplantılar
oluyordu ve Ben şunu fark ediyordum Biz
çok fazla eşitliği savunurken bir bakıma
kendimizi ayrılıyorduk yani ayırmaktan
kastım da Örneğin bir müdür ve bir
öğrenci yan yana gelemiyor du Çünkü
öğrenci kendini müdür eşit olduğunu
iddia ediyordu müdür ise ünvanından
dolayı öğrenci eşit olmadığını iddia
ediyordu hiçbir şekilde Ortak noktada
buluşamıyoruz vardı ve eşitsizlik
Aslında doğru Bu
ikincisi ve en önemlisi bu toplumda
bence büyük bir sorunu farklı olan
Aynıları Çünkü toplumda gerçekten
farklılaşmaya çalışan bir kesim var bunu
kabul etmemiz gerekiyor Bunu tamamen
kucaklamak gerekiyor çünkü baktığınız
zaman hepimiz son dönemde en azından
kapitalist düzenli yapılan bir şey var
markalar Örneğin a kişisi Bir arabayı
aldı zaman arabayı markası için oluyor
çünkü Bakın şu lüks markanın arabasına
biniyor diyorlar peki B kişisi akisi
gibi olmak istediği için aynı markayı
aldığı zaman size de çok ayrıl aşmıyor
mu yani biz bir bakıma farklılaşmaya
çalışırken şok daha Lan bir hale çok da
aynı hale gelmiyor muyuz İşte bu da
farkettiğim diğer sorulardan biriydi Z
kuşağının içinde bulunan sorumlulardan
biriydi
Burada iki yönü daha fark ettim Bunlar
ama çıkarımların değil tabii ki ama
birincisi şu Doğu Avrupa'da Türkiye'de
ve Asya'da milli ve yerli değil yani her
şeyi kendi ülkenizi üretmemiz tüm küçük
de bundan büyük parçalara kadar aklınıza
gelebilecek her şeyin milli ve yerli
olmasıydı ama en önemlisi olur ki yani
milli kelimesi bile Türkçeye sonradan
girmiş Arapça kökenli bir sözcüktür
Kısacası milli bile yeteri kadar milli
değildir ikinciye bakarsanız gençlik
çalıştayları
sanırım İki buçuk üç hafta önce falandır
çok önemli 1 toplantım vardı
Ankara'daydım ve arkadaşlarımla beraber
bir şeyler yapıyorduk ister istemez
açılış seremonileri kapanırsa
Ermenilerin en önemli konukları
getiririz her zaman dört tane komik
gelecekti ve konuşmacı listesinde 10
kişi vardı ve biz Tabii ki de onların
danışmanlığıyla bu isteği paylaşmıştık
önce bir şikayet Geldi Dediler ki bu
list10 kişi olamaz Neden olamaz dediler
ki geç mi konuşuyormuş dedi ki yani bu
listeyi değiştiremez Mesela kimse
çıkartmayı zaman ne yapabileceğimizi
söylerseniz yardımcı olmaya çalışalım
dediler ki o zaman biz ilk dörtlü olarak
konuşmak istiyoruz sonra konuşun de Bu
ay bir Size saygı duyuyoruz Bunu
yapabiliriz çünkü çok önemli isimlerdi
sonra toplantı başladı önce ilk kişi
çıktı iki kişi çıktı üçüncü kişi çıktı
dördüncü kişi çıktı ve bir anda
danışmanı bir tanesi geldi bana
kullanmadığı ki ara verebilir miyiz Ben
dedim ki verebiliriz Herhalde insan bir
durum var Ara verildiği zaman ilk kişi 3
eşiyle toparlayıp beraber çıktılar şimdi
buradaki ana mesaj Şu Biz orada gençlik
çalıştığı için varız orada 200 tane
neredeyse 15-16 ülkeden insan var ve her
biri benim için okunması gereken bir
sayfa Aslında
Dave dört kişi geldi hepsi dedi ki bir
geçti Çok önemsiyoruz Biz gençlere şunu
yapmak istiyoruz biz gençlerle şöyle
işbirliği kurmak istiyoruz ama işin
öncesi o ki hiçbiri gençler dinlemeye
dahi tenezzül etmedi bu da gördüm ikinci
bir problem Biz toplum olarak Z kuşağına
gümbür gümbür geliyor diyoruz ama hiçbir
zaman Z kuşağı nag Ama siz gümbür gümbür
geliyorsunuz ama nereye geliyorsunuz
sizin Amacınız ne demiyoruz ve onları
dinlemiyoruz Z kuşağı olarak bizimle
Aslında istediğimiz şey bu tanımak Çünkü
bize koşarak Herkesi tanıyoruz herkesi
biliyoruz bildiğimiz kadar da saygı
gösteriyoruz ama bence saygı dök
ediyoruz
bu Peki biz bu sorunları nasıl
açabiliriz 3 şey var Birincisi aktif
vatandaşlık aktif vatandaşlık çok basit
bir şey sizi ilgilendiren her kararda
sizin de söz hakkınız var yani Örneğin
bir şey yapılacak Beni ilgilendirmez Ben
yapmak istemiyorum demeyeceksiniz
gideceksiniz diyeceksiniz ki beni değil
ilgilendiriyor benim fikrim budur Eğer
bunu yaparsanız Aktif vatandaş olursunuz
ikincisi demokratik katılım Sırf siz
gidip oraya ben bunu yapılmasını
istiyorum dediniz diye farklı birinin
görüşlerini Red edemezsiniz çoğulcu
demokrasi olmak zorunda Evet kazananlar
veya fikirleri kabul edilenler size
değer verecek ama siz de Karara saygı
duyacaksınız Türkiye'nin en büyük bir
problemidir biz 65 80 darbesinde çok net
görmüşüzdür demokratik katılım Kendi
isteği olmadığı zaman yok olur ne olur
demokrasiye saygı duymaz üçüncüsü de
ortak mutabakat Z kuşağı da çok önemli
bir şey çünkü biz karar alır Allah hiç
kimseyi kırmıyoruz Evet herkesi memnun
edemeyiz bu konuda katılıyorum ama hiç
kimse kırmıyoruz Aktif vatandaş oluyoruz
demokratik katılıyoruz ve kararı kabul
edilmeyen bile bir şekilde çözümleri
sunuyoruz hep beraber ortak mutabakata
veriyoruz
ve Bu Yol Uzun bir süreç çünkü
Bence 20 ve 30 yıl sonra sonuçlarını
görebileceğimiz bir süreç ama Z kuşağı
olarak bu kadar merak edilen bu kadar ne
yapacağı gerçekten sorgulanan bir kuşağa
Bence yalnız bırakmamak lazım Kendi
tecrübeleri aktarılabilecek kendi yer
kuşakların bence bir şekilde iletişime
geçmesi gerektiğini düşünüyorum Ama şunu
da söyleyebilirim Z kuşağında ben sen o
Bizler Sizler yok Biz iki Kutup değiliz
hepimiz Z kuşağız Çünkü orwell'in 1984'ü
romanında biliyorsunuz bir distopya ben
bir kontrollü devletten bahseder bana
göre de öyledir 1950'de yazılmıştır
Çünkü 1950'de 1984'te ise 2020 yıllarda
2040 da odur Z kuşağı 20 sene sonra bazı
şeyleri eline aldığında hata yapmaması
için tecrübelerini alması gerekir diğer
kuşaklardan
buradan büyük birader de bir sözüm var
az önce söylediğim şeyi tekrar ama biz
de ben sen o yok bizsiz iki Kutup
ayrılmadık biz biriz beraberiz Çünkü Z
kuşağı olarak bizim büyük umutlarımız
var hayallerimiz var baskıya gelmeyiz
kısıtlandığını zaman bir çıkar yolu
buluruz ki sonra ne fark etmişsinizdir
Dünyanın her yerinde oluyor Bu bazen
bazı yayınlara izin verilmiyor veya
bazılarını konuşulmasına izin verilmiyor
bunu net bir şekilde söylemek istiyorum
şu an farkederseniz biz kısıtlanan tüm
yayınların yerine Z kuşağı olmak zorunda
değil başka gruplar tarafından
alternatif yayınlar üretiliyor O yüzden
kısıtlamak Tansa masaya çağırmak Onlarla
konuşmak en doğrusu Çünkü Z kuşağının
özelliği var oda Hayal kurmak Umudun
olmadığı hiçbir şekilde
gerçekleşmeyeceği düşündüğünüz anda Z
kuşağı mutlu anıyor ve bu umudunu da
gerçekleştirmek için herşeyi yapıyor bu
bu çünkü Z kuşağı hepimiz
Ben Son olarak şunu belirtmek istiyorum
biliyorsunuz 2022 yılındayız ve 20
yüzyıl İnanılır gibi değil ve halen Biz
Z kuşağı olarak bağırsak Bunalım larımız
diğer kuşakların dediği gibi beraber
Usta sancılarınız içinde dinlenirken
hala dünyanın bir kenarlarında Savaş
ekonomik kriz veya farklı şekilde
kavramları duyuyoruz şunu söyleyebilirim
Z kuşağı bir temsilcisi olarak biz her
zaman barıştan yanayız Barış olmalı ki
insan olsun Barış olsun ki insan emeği
olsun Çünkü insan emeği Bence en değerli
şeydir
orwell'in 1984'ü de şöyle der savaşın
vazgeçilmez yanı sadece insan hayatının
değil İnsan emeğinin öldürülmesi dir
Gerçekten öyledir bir insanı beş
saniyede öldürürsünüz ama emeğini
öldürdüğü zaman belki yine on saniye
süren 15 saniye sürer ama onu geri
getirmek insanı geri getirmekten çok
daha zordur O yüzden zevk kuş olarak biz
kesinlikle ve kesinlikle emeğin
katledilme bu ve herhangi bir savaşa
karşıyız Biz Son olarak şunu
söyleyebilirim Bu var olsa sancılar
içerisinde ben de varım ve benim yol
arkadaşım var hadi Haluk çok derin bir
adam Hataylı
bazen beraber sohbet ederiz bazen müzik
dinleriz ve
24şubat olması lazım 24şubat günü de
akşam ışığın kapatmıştı Haberlere
bakıyoruz pek tatlı şeyler yoktu Son
dönemdeki gerginliklerden zaten
biliyorsunuzdur ve dedim ki hala yağışlı
kapatalım Müzik dinleyelim ve ben bir
şeyler yazmak istiyorum Ve o gün de
aslında bu çıktı Ben buna toplumun
kendini zıtlaşması bir ürünü diyorum
Çünkü savaş ve barış ne kadar zıt sa
toplumun içindeki kuşaklar dışarıda
birini o kadar zıt ya kırgın değilim
kırgınlık hastalarda olur hasta değil
Henüz aklına getirmedim bugün değilim
Evet Vuruldum ama ölmedim ben Kolundaki
saat kadar dakik zihnindeki kahvaltılar
kadar özgürüm Bozguna değilim o
savaşlarda olur anlattılar okulda Sen
benim sen beni görme Sen de sana
nefesini isteyecek kadar yakın bir
yabancı kadar uzağa Barış Benim adım
uzun yoldan geldim sana papatyalar
getirdim bir oradayım Bir buradayım sana
senden daha yakın barışta kalın
teşekkürler
[Alkış]
abone ol